Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P Here is the eggman
calling in about yes, my my cameo
in a Netflix documentary about Malaysian Airlines
Flight 370, which I guess is like one of the top
things in the country right now. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hey, I don't know if you mentioned
this on your program yet, but yeah, you
know that you're in the MH 370. The Plane
that Disappeared is documentary on Netflix.
Yeah. In the second episode, it's a David
Pakman cameo. I'm sure you know this. I'm sure
you've already said that, but it's implying like
you're almost a conspiracy guy about, you
know, some pattern or something. Anyway,
it was really neat to see you. Yeah, I'm stuck
in the middle of the night when I'm watching TV.
Speaker 1: Shallow brother. Yeah. Shalom to the
egg, man. I hope you had a good Purim. Listen,
I am probably tomorrow or the day after are
going to do a full segment about my appearance
in that documentary where they absolutely
make me sound like a conspiracy theorist
by using a clip in which I am debunking a
conspiracy theory. Now, I'm also not going to
blame anybody by my but myself for what happened.
And I'm going to explain all of this tomorrow.
But I am not happy with the way in which I was
included in that. I now know what I did wrong.
A contract lawyer reached out to me and we
exchanged a couple of emails. They framed me
as a conspiracy theorist using a clip where
I'm debunking a conspiracy. Let's talk about
it tomorrow or Wednesday. I will tell you what's
going on. We have a fantastic bonus show for you
today. Tucker Carlson's ex producer, was worried
about their, quote, dumb viewers falling for the
lies that they were telling. It's a fascinating
peek behind the curtain. A new poll suggests that
Ron Desantis's Anti-woke crusade might actually
backfire on him. And we will talk about listen to
this. Every year, daylight savings, we talk about
the movement for permanent daylight savings. There
is a movement against permanent daylight savings,
and it's a different perspective. I'll explain to
you what they believe, why we'll evaluate whether
it makes sense and then whatever. I'll take a
nap because I'm tired from the time change. So
that'll be the plan for the bonus show. I will
nap during the show, which will be a new thing.
Might be interesting to some people. Sign up for
membership at join Pacman dot com. You'll get
instant access to the bonus show the commercial
free audio and video feeds of the show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: All right. All right. Let's settle down
and invitations to member only town hall events,
the next of which is coming up pretty soon. Sign
up for join Pacman dot com. I'll see you then.